FOR NOW, SEAN HANNITY LIVE FROM
NEW YORK CITY.
>> Sean: GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS,
BUCKLE UP.
ALL EYES ARE ON THE MIDDLE EAST,
EARLIER THIS MORNING A
SURVEILLANCE DRONE FLYING ABOVE
THE STRAIT OF HORMUZ OVER
INTERNATIONAL WATERS SHOT OUT OF
THE SKY BY AN IRANIAN MISSILE,
THIS ACT OF AGGRESSION IS NOT
GOING TO STAND, THE PRESIDENT IS
PUTTING THE MULLAHS OF IRAN ON
NOTICE, TONIGHT THEY SHOULD BE
VERY, VERY WORRIED.
THIS WAS A BAD IDEA, TAKE A LOO
LOOK.
>> IRAN MADE A BIG MISTAKE.
THIS DRONE WAS IN INTERNATIONAL
WATERS, WE HAVE A DOCUMENTED,
DOCUMENTED SCIENTIFICALLY, NOT
JUST WORDS.
THEY MADE A BAD MISTAKE.
[REPORTER QUESTIONING]
>> YOU'LL FIND OUT.
YOU'LL FIND OUT.
[REPORTER QUESTIONING]
>> WE AREN'T GOING TO BE TALKING
TOO MUCH ABOUT IT, THEY MADE A
VERY BIG MISTAKE.
>> Sean: THEY MADE A VERY BIG
MISTAKE, THEY WILL PAY.
TONIGHT THE PRESIDENT IS CLEARLY
GIVING THE MULLAHS AN OPENING TO
PICK UP THE PHONE AND COME CLEAN
WITH HER HOSTILE BEHAVIOR.
I LIKE THAT PATIENTS, WHAT ABOUT
ALL THE LIBERALS WHO SAID
DONALD TRUMP IS ROGUE AND WE
CAN'T TRUST HIM?
HE'S BEING VERY PATIENT.
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS
RELEASED THIS STATEMENT "RAN
ATTACKED A U.S. ASSET OVER
INTERNATIONAL WATERS, THIS
PROVOCATION COMES AFTER THEY
ATTACKED AND DESTROYED TWO
COMMERCIAL TANKERS IN
INTERNATIONAL WATERS.
THERE MUST BE A MEASURED
RESPONSE TO THESE ACTIONS."
HOW DO WE DEFINE MEASURED?
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES NOT WANT
WAR, HE'S NOT INTERESTED IN
ANOTHER YEARS AND YEARS LONG
INTERNATIONAL ENTANGLEMENT, I
DON'T EXPECT ONE.
IN COMING DAYS, WE WILL KNOW IF
THE MULLAHS ARE SMART ENOUGH TO
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY WHICH IS A
SMALL WINDOW -- IT MAY NOT EVEN
EXIST WITHIN 5 MINUTES.
IF THEY DON'T COME OF THE
PRESIDENT WILL HAVE NO CHOICE,
HE WILL BOMB THE HILL OUT OF
THEM.
NO NEED FOR A LONG PROTRACTED
BOOTS ON THE GROUND, WE HAVE THE
GREATEST MILITARY ON THE FACE OF
THE EARTH, THE MOST ADVANCED
WEAPON SYSTEM, AND A STRONG
MESSAGE NEEDS TO BE SENT THAT A
HUGE PRICE WILL BE PAID IF YOU
TAKE ON THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
SIMPLE PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH
AND IT WORKS.
MY STRONG OPINION, IT'S
IMPERATIVE WE AS A COUNTRY
DEVELOP WHAT I CALL THE NEXT
GENERATION OF MILITARY WEAPONRY.
WE HAVE LEARNED FROM VIETNAM, WE
HAVE LEARNED FROM IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN.
SADLY, WARS WE GET INVOLVED IN
QUICKLY BECOME POLITICIZED.
THEY DO NOT END AS THEY SHOULD
WITH COMPLETE VICTORY.
WE DON'T WANT OUR KIDS GOING
DOOR-TO-DOOR LIKE THEY DID IN
IRAQ AND HAVING DEMOCRATS SAY
COME HOME AND THEN BEING TOLD
NEVER MIND, WE DIDN'T MEAN IT.
AMERICA NEEDS THE SINGLE MOST
ADVANCED WEAPONRY FOR ALL FUTURE
CONFLICTS, I PREFER WE DEVASTATE
OUR ENEMIES FROM TAMPA, FLORIDA,
THAT GENERATION OF WEAPONRY IS
SOMETHING WE NEED TO ADVANCE AS
A COUNTRY QUICKLY AND
EXPEDITIOUSLY.
THANKFULLY TONIGHT WE ARE IN A
NEW ERA, THE WEEK FECKLESS
BIDEN-OBAMA POLICY IS DEAD AND
GONE, THERE WILL BE NO MORE
SHIPMENTS OF CASH AND CARGO
PLANES FOR THE MULLAHS IN
TEHRAN.
THERE WILL BE NO MORE BRIBES OR
EUROPEAN FROLICS FOR JOHN KERRY,
THERE WILL BE NO UNITED NATIONS,
THIS IS A DIFFERENT TIME.
THERE WILL BE HELL TO PAY AND
THE WORLD IS WATCHING, TRYING TO
TONIGHT'S WATCHING, RUSHING IS
WATCHING.
THE NORTH KOREANS ARE WATCHING.
A QUICK "HANNITY" HISTORY
LESSON -- IT'S NO MYSTERY WHY
IRAN IS ACTING OUT.
HOW THIS HAPPENED I CANNOT
EXPLAIN, IT IS INEXPLICABLE.
THE SINGLE DUMBEST FOREIGN
POLICY DEAL EVER MADE IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY,
BIDEN-OBAMA LITERALLY LOOSENED
ECONOMIC SANCTIONS ON IRAN AFTER
THEY HAD A CHANCE TO SUPPORT
YOUNG FREEDOM FIGHTERS, THE
YOUNGER GENERATION THAT WANTED
HELP THAT WERE QUOTING JEFFERSON
AND WASHINGTON AND FRAMERS AND
FOUNDERS -- BIDEN-OBAMA GIFTED
THE RADICAL ISLAMIC MULLAHS OF
IRAN $150 BILLION IN CASH AND
CURRENCY -- IN EXCHANGE THE
IRANIAN GOVERNMENT MADE AN
UNVERIFIABLE PROMISE NOT TO
BUILD A NUCLEAR WEAPON FOR YEARS
BUT THEY CAN DO IT IN TEN YEARS.
THE RADICAL ISLAMIC EXTREMIST
GOVERNMENT OF IRAN CONTINUED TO
FUND TERRORISM AS THEY ALWAYS
HAVE ALL OVER THE WORLD, PROXY
WARS.
THEY CONTINUE TO CHANT DEATH TO
ISRAEL, DEATH TO AMERICA, THEY
CONTINUE TO BURN THE AMERICAN
FLAG, THE ISRAELI FLAG.
THEY ARE A HOSTILE ACT OR TO THE
REGION AND THANKS TO BIDEN-OBAMA
THEY HAVE A BOATLOAD OF CASH TO
SPEND FOMENTING TERROR AROUND
THE WORLD.
ALL OF THIS CHANGED TO
JANUARY 20TH 2017.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS INAUGURATED,
HE PULLED THE UNITED STATES OUT
OF THIS HORRIFIC NUCLEAR DEAL,
HE REIMPOSED A DEVASTATING
SANCTIONS AND THEY ARE WORKING.
TONIGHT, IRAN FEELING THE
EFFECTS OF THE PRESIDENT'S
POLICIES, THEY ARE FEELING IT IN
A BIG WAY BECAUSE OF THE
REIMPOSED SANCTIONS.
THEY ARE NOW FACING YEARS LONG
RECESSION.
2018, THEIR ECONOMY RETRACTED BY
A WHOPPING 4%.
THIS YEAR THE INTERNATIONAL
MONETARY FUND IS PREDICTING IRAN
WILL LOSE ANOTHER 6%.
INFLATION A MASSIVE ISSUE IN
IRAN, 2019 A LOAN, INFLATION
LIKELY TO TOP 40%.
MEANWHILE, OUR ECONOMY IS
BOOMING BECAUSE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S EFFORTS TO UNLEASH
AMERICAN ENERGY, WE ARE IN THE
BEST POSITION WE HAVE EVER BEEN
IN AS IT RELATES TO ANY CONFLICT
IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
WE ARE SHIELDED FROM THE CRISIS
BECAUSE OF COURSE THE LIFEBLOOD
OF EVERY ECONOMY IS OIL AND GAS,
NOT THE NEW GREEN DEAL.
THE IRANIAN ECONOMY HAS LOST THE
VALUE AS WE HAVE BECOME ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
WE ARE NOW THE NUMBER ONE
PRODUCER OF OIL AND NATURAL GAS
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS,
AMERICA IS ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
WE ARE A NET EXPORTER OF ENERGY.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE HAVE THEIR
LEVERAGE.
IF WE DON'T NEED THE
STRAIT OF HORMUZ AS WE ONCE DID
AND IRAN IS SUFFERING
ECONOMICALLY.
THE IRANIAN PEOPLE ARE GROWING
MORE AND MORE ANGRY AND
FRUSTRATED WITH THEIR RADICAL
GOVERNMENT.
IRAN'S ARMED FORCES CANNOT MATCH
THE MIGHT OF OUR MILITARY.
NOW THE MULLAHS MUST SEE THE
RIDING IS ON THE WALL.
THEY EITHER STOP FUNDING TERROR,
PROXY WARS, STOP ATTACKING SHIPS
IN THE GULF OF OMAN, STOP
PLOTTING THE ANNIHILATION OF
ISRAEL OUR CLOSEST ALLY IN THE
MIDDLE EAST, AND THE
UNITED STATES.
IF THEY DO NOT END THIS
HOSTILITY, IF THEY DO NOT STOP,